CAMPAIGN OR THE WHITE HOUSE.
SHE WAS VERY RESPECTED AND I
THINK SHE DID A GOOD JOB FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> Laura: ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU
BOTH.
NO MATTER WHAT COMES OF THE
PFIZER INVESTIGATION, DEMOCRATS
ARE HOPING THAT SPECIAL
PROSECUTOR BOB MUELLER WILL FIND
EVIDENCE OF WRONGDOING BY THE
PRESIDENT.
REPUBLICAN STRATEGISTS AND I'M
CONFIDENT ROGER STONE JOINS US
NOW TO SHARE WHAT HE BELIEVES
MUELLER IS NOW INVESTIGATING.
ROGER JOINS US FROM MIAMI.
ROGER, GREAT TO SEE YOU.
THESE LEAKS KEEP COMING OUT,
DON'T THEY, OF THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION?
WE'LL GET INTO A LOT OF IT.
SOME OF IT IS NOW SEEMING TO
FOCUS ON WHETHER DONALD TRUMP
KNEW ABOUT THOSE WIKILEAKS HACKS
OR THE EMAILS THAT WIKILEAKS HAD
OF JOHN PODESTA AND THE DNC, AND
YOUR NAME KEEPS POPPING UP AS A
POTENTIAL INTERMEDIARY BETWEEN,
I GUESS, IMPLIED, THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN AND JULIAN ASSANGE.
I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN THROUGH THIS
BEFORE, BUT IT'S ALL OUT TODAY.
>> THIS IS AN ATTEMPT BY THE
HANDMAIDENS OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY AND THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA
TO REINFLATE THE INFLATED
RUSSIAN COLLUSION DELUSION.
LET'S BE VERY CLEAR.
THE TRUNCATED DOCTORED
SCREENSHOT PUBLISHED BY THE
"ATLANTIC" MAGAZINE ACTUALLY
PROVES THAT I HAD NO ADVANCED
KNOWLEDGE OF THE SOURCE OR
CONTENT OF THE WIKILEAKS
DISCLOSURES REGARDING
HILLARY CLINTON AND I NEVER
CLAIMED THAT I DID.
JULIE AND ASSANGE HIMSELF HAS
SAID, "ROGER STONE MERELY
RETREATED AND FOLLOWED WHAT I
DID, ABSOLUTELY TRUE."
AND TO BE ABSOLUTELY CLEAR, I
NEVER DISCUSS THE WIKILEAKS
DISCLOSURES REGARDING HILLARY OR
JOHN PODESTA, WHICH I ALSO HAD
NO KNOWLEDGE OF COME UP WITH
CANDIDATE DONALD TRUMP, BEFORE,
DURING, OR AFTER THE ELECTION.
THERE IS JUST LITERALLY NOTHING
THERE.
NOW, ALL THIS MATERIAL THAT WAS
RELEASED TODAY HAD BEEN TURNED
OVER TO THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE MONTHS AGO.
BUT THIS IS AN ATTEMPT TO,
ESSENTIALLY, REINFLATE A FALSE
NARRATIVE.
>> Laura: DON'T YOU ALSO SEE A
SHIFT HAPPEN, ROGER.
THEY WERE SET ON THE COLLUSION
NARRATIVE AND THEY TRIED, BUT IT
DOESN'T SEEM TO BE REALLY GOING
ANYWHERE.
YOU SENSE THEY ARE MOVING TO A
COMPROMISE NARRATIVE, NAMELY
THAT THE PRESIDENT REPORTEDLY
MUST BE COMPROMISED IN SOME WAY
BY RUSSIA, HENCE HIS SOFT
TREATMENT OF RUSSIA.
AND I WANT TO PLAY SOMETHING FOR
YOU FROM YOUR DEAR FRIEND THIS
MORNING ON CNN.
LET'S WATCH.
>> WHY HAS DONALD TRUMP BEEN SO
FAVORABLE TO VLADIMIR PUTIN?
WHAT IS IN IT FOR HIM?
>> A VERY CLEAR POSSIBILITY IS
BUSINESS, MONEY, THAT HE HAS
BUSINESS DEALINGS IN RUSSIA THAT
HE HAS WANTED TO CULTIVATE.
I JUST WROTE A STORY IN "THE
NEW YORKER" ABOUT WHEN HE
BROUGHT THE MISS UNIVERSE
PAGEANT TO MOSCOW IN 2013.
THAT LED DIRECTLY TO THE MEETING
AND TRUMP TOWER IN JUNE OF 2016.
>> Laura: NOW, ROGER, THE
MISS UNIVERSE PAGEANT IS BROUGHT
INTO THE EQUATION ON THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION.
ASIDE FROM THE RANK SPECULATION
BY TOOBIN?
>> IF WE ARE SO PRO-PUTIN, WHY
IS HE BRINGING THAT OVER THE
ADAMANT OBJECTION OF THE
RUSSIANS?
DONALD TRUMP DIDN'T WANT TO GO
TO WAR OVER SYRIA AND
HILLARY CLINTON WAS PROMISING
THE DEEP STATE AND EXPANSION OF
THE WAR THERE.
IF YOU LOOK AT SYRIA, ASSAD HAD
THAT, ON THE OTHER SIDE, YOU
HAVE ISIS AND A THOUSAND OTHER
RADICAL GROUPS.
WE HAVE NO PLACE HERE.
DONALD TRUMP DOES NOT WANT TO
SPEND BORROWED AMERICAN MONEY OR
AMERICAN LIVES GOING TO WAR WITH
RUSSIA OVER SYRIA.
A NO-FLY ZONE AS FAVORED BY
HILLARY CLINTON AND
JOHN McCAIN WOULD HAVE BEEN AN
INDICATION FOR A WORLD WAR III.
DONALD TRUMP WAS THE PEACE
CANDIDATE IN THE LAST ELECTION.
HE HAS NO ILLUSIONS ABOUT RUSSIA
OR THE FACT THAT PUTIN IS A BAD
GUY, BUT THEY HAVE THERMONUCLEAR
WEAPONS, LAURA.
PERHAPS WE SHOULD BE TALKING TO
THEM.
>> Laura: AND THE IDEA THAT
TRUMP IS SOMEHOW SOFTER ON THE
RUSSIANS THEN OBAMA WAS -- I
MEAN, OBAMA'S BIG PUSH WAS
DECEMBER 2016, OKAY, WE'RE GOING
TO KICK THESE RUSSIAN OFFICIALS
OUT OF THE COUNTRY.
BUT THEY WERE TRYING TO DO THE
RESET, THEY HAD TO DEAL WITH
BILL CLINTON, THE SECRETARY OF
STATE, URANIUM ONE.
I THINK THE ARGUMENT IS CLEAR
THAT, IF ANYONE WAS SOFT ON
RUSSIA, IT WAS OBAMA.
IT WASN'T TRUMP.
IT WAS OBAMA WHO WAS SOFT.
>> THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA IS
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT ABOUT THE FACT
THAT THERE WAS A MAJOR PARTY
CANDIDATE WHOSE AIDS WERE IN BED
WITH THE OLIGARCHS AROUND
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
THERE WAS ONE CANDIDATE WHOSE
FOUNDATION WAS TAKING MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS FROM RUSSIAN
INTERESTS.
THAT WOULD BE THE REAL      HILA
THAT WOULD BE THE REAL      HILY
THAT WOULD BE THE REAL      HILR
THAT WOULD BE THE REAL      HILD
THAT WOULD BE THE REAL      HILA
THAT WOULD BE THE REAL      HILM
CLINTON.
THE PANAMA PAPERS PUBLISHED IN
JANUARY OF 2016 EXPOSED TO THE
PODESTA BROTHERS' DEALINGS,
SHADY DEALINGS, AND RUSSIA, THE
GAS DEAL, THE BANKING DEAL.
THIS IS ALL A MATTER OF PUBLIC
RECORDS.
SHE WAS THE CANDIDATE IN BED
WITH PUTIN, NOT DONALD TRUMP.
>> Laura: BY THE WAY, ROGER, I
KNOW YOU LOVE THIS STORY,
JEFF SESSIONS IS DINING AT A